how's it going guys matt here from code
tech tutorials and just wanted to go
over some r
slash cpp questions courtesy of reddit
and its user base over there
so the first
question c plus programs wrongly flagged
as virus so you're running software
testing things out
antivirus pops up thinks programs virus
tries to remove it tries to delete it
tries to make a report
and how do you fix this the best answer
seems to be
from
r
you should be able to exclude your build
directory as well as intermediate files
from your antivirus so you probably need
to go to your antivirus and say hey
things that are going on here
don't don't even scan
that's probably the best answer because
as you're playing around with memory you
know c plus is a pretty powerful
language you're going to be doing stuff
that antivirus will pick up
as hey you're moving memory around in a
weird way i'm not used to see it there's
not proper checking whatever your
antivirus is doing
it's yeah it's pretty normal when you're
learning to code with c plus and yeah i
would say just do this
that's probably the best thing you can
do
there are some other answers here to
make your program not be flagged you
need to sign the executable okay if
that's not something that interests you
you probably are selling or distributed
to untrusted users in that case usually
by seeing the flagging and run it anyway
either pay for a certificate or have
your friend authorize the individual
program click the link and just tell the
os the program is safe you need to sign
your executable with valid keys
so those are some more advanced things
some pretty solid answers there let's go
on to the next question
the best c plus plus book for an
intermediate python programmer this is a
really odd question to ask in here to be
honest best book it's good
you can always get lists of the best
books
whenever you want just search for a list
of the best books
of whatever the topic is but for an
intermediate python programmer that's
where this question gets odd to me
c plus plus
let's just see what the answers say yes
what the best book is
and this guy just says get a book
just get a book all right
well
it looks like he does go on to say some
useful stuff other than just get a book
or go to learncbp.com
i don't know about learncbp i haven't
went through all of it i i found that it
didn't there was something that wasn't
right
about it to me
i wasn't i felt like i wasn't learning
very well
so i didn't get very far in it but that
was like also three or four years ago so
the learn cbb might be completely
different now
so i'm not going to fully discredit it
because i i don't know anymore start
from the beginning in either case c plus
is vastly more different than python you
need a basic understanding of how the
computer cpu memory and os works
things that python completely hide for
you
i don't think
python completely hides this
but i'm not an expert with python just
when you see a word like completely you
generally know that it's a false
statement no matter what they're saying
okay we got another answer here a tour
of c plus plus intended to be the first
overview of a language for programmers
already know who had different languages
that that's a good answer a torah c plus
plus is probably pretty good looks like
uh
if someone asked me this i would
generally say
i can speak for the books that i've
learned from this one is very good it's
probably actually a lot like a tour of c
plus
its principles and practices using c
plus plus
it gives a lot of good examples about
how to do common things that you would
want to do that really helped me at
times holy crap this price has gone up
anyway i'll leave a link to this down
below uh i'll scroll through some other
ones
but generally these you can you can kind
of trust these stars
for the quality of these books
especially when they've got a lot you
know 4.5 is pretty solid you're going to
get a pretty decent understanding of the
language from these books
but one thing i've noticed
about these programming books and about
learning c plus in general is
you kind of have to learn c as well
because a lot of c plus has
some c
in it somewhere that either is legacy or
hasn't
they haven't made a better way to do
with the standard library or or
something like that
so i would also recommend learning the
basics of c in general if you're
learning c plus plus
so you might want to
pick a book or just go through a crash
course on that it's going to talk a
little more about the memory management
that's some fundamental stuff so there's
a lot of other books here i can't really
speak for any of these
but as you can see there's plenty with
pretty high rankings
so when in doubt yeah sure take a few
recommendations but also just pick up
some that seem best for you
that if you're into game development you
could put
like game dev on here and you'll see
some good ones
let's go on to the next question
here's a good one how do you guys test
and import libraries this is something i
talk a lot about on the channel in
general i have some experience with
people's applause however i
haven't written much software just
wanted to write a small library and i've
run into problems how do you test it how
to use it in other apps i have like a
gazillion videos on these two subjects
mostly how to use in other apps but it's
basically the same because if you can
use another app you can test it you just
check that it's doing what it's supposed
to be doing with your app basically for
a test yeah there are frameworks and
that's a lot of side topics i plan on
making some detailed videos about using
some test libraries
one of the top answers here is basically
use a package manager if you're on
windows vc pkg is great conan's probably
great i haven't used a lot myself
yeah sure you could set set it up in
conan so that your other global stuff
sees it but that's he's talking about
just linking it basically what you do is
you link your library i'll leave a video
down below that explains this in a
couple different ways or you can just
search my channel for
like sleepless plus libraries because i
have some how to's on that sort of stuff
it's not like a simple answer sure i
could give you a quick answer like you
just link it but if you don't even know
what that means like you're gonna be
lost right yeah that's why some of these
questions are hard to answer is because
kind of need more scenarios about
exactly what you're doing to give you
like a direct answer but you can go get
a broad knowledge of it and that's going
to be really helpful
when you're new and as far as testing if
you're on windows
uh just use
either c test from c make which i need
to make a video on if you're using
visual studio there's
there's also tests here you can you can
go to file
new project
and then you go to
native unit test
so this is just the
little test library that comes with this
and you basically you get another
project
so like you know in this project i have
my main library which is named a engine
and this core test is a native unit test
so yeah you have to link your library to
it uh and the easiest way to do that is
to actually just right click on it
and go to add
and then reference
and then just check on your library
and it should set up the majority of the
stuff
and this core test you do have to build
it
and then you go to tests run all tests
so this is what i use when i don't feel
like
working hard basically and downloading
google tests and setting up different
ones this the native if i hit play it's
going to run this example project it's
not what i want
so to run the tests you go up to tests
while testing you don't see it
you got to go to test explorer probably
and then you should have a run all tests
here and you can also run individual
tests
and you go write these tests there's
examples from microsoft but basically it
gives you this little framework where
you make these test methods give it a
name do whatever you want make some
asserts in there
uh to make sure it's doing what you
think it's doing
really really basic tests there
but you get the point
but in general it's gonna look something
like that for testing
concurrency and c plus player plus
looking for good resources for
multi-threading c plus plus another
really big subject yeah i would say just
start with a good reputable
resource and start simple start really
simple with multi-threading because it
gets confusing real quick and you
probably want to have a good
understanding of some of the stuff we've
talked about earlier in this video like
the core concepts of c and c plus plus
because you get really kind of deep into
memory management with multi-threading
as you need to decide which threads are
working on what and
make sure they're not both trying to
write to the same piece of memory at the
same time this is true there are lots of
cpp contacts and i'm sure there's
plenty of books on it too
but yeah that's as specific as i'm going
to get on this one let's go to the next
question accessing map elements
explanation all right so he has a
question just confused about
what this line
is accessing can i understand it for the
life okay
well it's uh
answer equals equals zero well this is a
boolean check and it's multiplying
by
begin which is going to be the first
element of the map so it's uh it's
multiplying a true or false so if this
is false it's going to be zero it's
going to multiply by zero and if it's
true it's who knows it should be a one
but it's not necessarily going to be a
one
so all right mp dot begin so first
element of the map and the second part
of that so a map has a key and a value
the key which it would be called first
here is uh like a string or an
or some unique element that can't be
repeated the second
is what it maps to
so it's whatever
the second element is of the map or
whatever the value is at the start of
the map
i hope that makes sense i could probably
draw it real quick so a map is
essentially a ordered list of pairs and
when you have a map
just
say map here and you give it a name
we're just going to call ours all the
same thing that had mp so you fill it up
with element it has two different values
one here
and we'll say one here this one is the
key
and this one is
the value associated with that key so
you have
a bunch of these and that's basically
the keys in a map are unique
if you try to add another one with the
same key
it will overwrite the value because
that's also a way you can access the
values is by the map key they are not
doing that here they are instead using
begin
which is going to be
an iterator
that points to the very first thing in
the map so if you've got a big list of
them it's pointing to the very first one
at the top
and it's going to be ordered so it
should be based on the key however it
comes
based on your ordering algorithm and
second
access is the value of it so it's
accessing this if they said
first they'd be accessing the key which
you generally don't want to do that
usually you find it by the key and you
want the value
so yeah i would expect this
see like they're uh i don't know if this
is a mistake or not this this whole
thing here answer equals equals zero is
just going to be a true false basically
it's just checking if it's true or false
and then they're multiplying it by
whatever the second value is i i clean i
can't fathom
why this would be a thing to do
but i hope that explains maps just the
multiplying by a true or false really
confuses me maybe
someone that's new wrote this code and
this is supposed to be dereferencing and
they're not aware of what this does or
something like that it's my guess all
right let's go on to the next question
this isn't a question this is the demand
i request all of you kindly give me a
list professional claim list of c plus
certificates this is a bad question
because it's not a question it's a
demand i'm getting the impression that
this guy doesn't speak good english so
he might not be aware of how he's
wording this
but to just
go to a question forum and start a
question with a demand of i request all
of you to give me your list of something
it's a little awkward okay you're
probably not gonna get any good
responses probably gonna get snarky
comments but it would be better to say
are there any c plus plus
certificates that are worth getting
question mark
there's a good answer down here in the
past when i asked a manager who hired me
for my first c plus plus job he left
it's not really something you get
certified in you can generally figure it
out by what pieces of software the
person has produced the certifications
don't really mean that much
it means a lot more to have
things under your belt that kind of
prove
your skills the certificates are just
fluff that they don't
necessarily equal reality
programming is really hard and if you
mess it up really badly it's going to
cause serious problems it's not like
in other
areas where you can say hey i've
attended this course i i understand what
you guys expect this is like
it's
very math and science related so
there isn't really room for
interpretation it's like the memory
works exactly how it works
you either understand it or you don't
and the certificate is
you can say that you showed up somewhere
or went through something
but
unless we actually see your proof of
concept in your own work you can't
really rely on the certificate to
to mean much
yeah i hope that helps
let's go on the next one
here's an interesting one i want to make
an mp4 to mp3 file converter and cpp i
don't want to use libraries
where do i start how difficult will this
be
okay i hear that you don't want to
use libraries but here's here's the
thing
they've probably already done it
and i'm not saying use the library i'm
saying go look at their source and see
how they do it
and you'll have your answer
and if you don't understand the source
it's going to be a scale of 11 to do if
you understand the source
it's going to be like a 1 or 2. so
there's a pretty big gap in there
you might be able to like
another thing you could do if you don't
want to look at their source
because these are open source i'm pretty
sure uh you could look at the very
specific binary details of how an mp4
works and how an mp3 works
uh maybe it's not binary i'm not sure i
haven't looked at them
precisely
and you could
come up with your own way to do the
conversions
and who knows maybe you'll come up with
something that nobody else did and
you'll be able to improve
libraries or come up with your own but
the best place to start is probably to
look at these libraries and just see how
they do it
let's see what other people answered
you need to re-encode oh this guy says
11 you need to re-encode
yeah that's
if you need to ask this question you
haven't learned
enough c plus plus yeah it's i'd say
that's true it's kind of basically what
i'd say
well i think that answers that well
enough let's go on to the next one we
got one more okay this is an odd
question we seem to get a lot of these
here
function objects question mark hey so
why is passing a function object
faster than passing a function
that doesn't even make sense i don't
even know i don't even know what that
means i could try to tear it apart and
understand it but i think he's just
doesn't quite understand something he's
missing something
this is true only if the object is small
or passed by reference or
and if the function call operator is
small and defined to be inline you even
know what you're talking about but
here's my problem where's you where are
you getting this information what are
you talking let's just continue what if
i define a function in line
and then
pass it to a function isn't it faster
than a function
oh my god what is it what's happening
okay this does bring up a good point
though
i would be happy someone explained no
one's going to be able to explain that
because your question doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense
i think what you're looking at or what
you're talking about
you're either talking about lambdas
and how they work and
c plus plus can be used as a totally
functional
language you don't have to use it as an
object-oriented language exclusively
you can do a lot of functional stuff you
basically use a lot of lambdas assign
lambdas
as an object you can say hey this uh
this function
is equal
to this or whatever you basically make a
variable
and the variable is a function and you
can pass that function somewhere and
that's but if he's also maybe he's
asking about passing by reference or
passing a pointer to a function so like
when you have a function defined let me
just write an example real quick okay so
the first lambdas
if you're in a modern version c plus
plus you can have a variable named
whatever you want and you can set it
equal
to a lambda which looks like this this
is basically a blank function that does
nothing this is what it captures from
your current scope and this one here is
what you're passing in
and this one here is what it does
and then you can
use this var
anytime you want
like so and it'll call the function
so that's essentially a lambda go look
more at lambdas if you're confused about
that there's a lot you can do with them
but that's like the very very basics
right there so let's move past the
lambda thing for now and let's talk
about functions now this really comes
with the basics of functions so
they look like this right they have a
return type
a name
all the values that pass in
and then whatever it does and somewhere
in here you need to return
whatever expects and if you don't want
to return anything and you just want to
do something make a void and there's a
lot of different ways to operate about
these
so
this
this pass in just
declaring it like this this will make
copies of whatever a was and whatever b
was so if you call it
say we have
float
a value 1 and a value 2.
and then we want to call this example
function on them
s and value 1
by u2
that will make a copy of value 1
and a copy of value 2. even if you use
the same names it'll still make copies
that's not relevant
it's called shadowing if you end up
using the same names but in different
scopes
don't do that try to avoid that at least
if you're okay with them being copies
then that's fine because you could say
return let's just do an operation we
could just do a times b
and it would return what you would
expect
i could write this in different ways
such as we could hold the value result a
times b
and then return the result it just
depends on how you want to do your
processing because you might want to say
something like i don't know check if
result is greater than 10 you might want
to clamp it for example then result
equals 10.
and you can do the same for whatever you
want
before you return so it just it really
just depends on how your function is but
let's talk about a few other things so
what if you put const here well
typically you want positive course it
varies depending on what you're doing
but like ninety percent of the time you
want const here because that basically
says
this value can't change don't change
this value
which is typically what you want in a
function but not always
because what if
if these are not cons then you can play
with these copies
you could
say let's just
assign a a new value and you can start
doing recursive things or whatever
you want or a recursive might not be the
right word for it
you don't want to recurse this function
because it would make copies of these
let's not talk about recursion
it's just going to make this more
confusing all right but basically if
they're not const you can legally assign
them and change them but that's not
going to change the ones you passed in
because these are copies
however
if you do this if you say
bring them in by reference
you're actually working with these
original values so value one value two
if you're suddenly bringing them in by
reference whatever you change them to
will reflect so maybe that's what he's
talking about in the question
and usually when you're doing that
maybe
you're returning a success value because
you're having your results already
stored somewhere and usually you want to
label these as
outs or something like that
out
so we could say
we can make this void
and we don't have to return anything we
could say no you can't change a no you
can't change b
but bring them in by reference
and this is the fastest
because you're not making a copy
and there's no risk of accidentally
changing these values but this one here
that you want to be the out value is not
const because you want to be able to
change it and this is one of the fastest
performing functions because
well there's no copies being made so
maybe that's what he's asking so it's
worth it to get an understanding
of how this reference things works
sure you could also do it by pointer and
that's going to make that's going to
bring in a copy of a pointer which is
notably much smaller than the piece of
data
but you have to be careful because this
pointer is the only thing that's const
in this situation the data that it's
pointing to is not const you can still
have
problems yeah i hope that explains it
as well as can be if you don't
understand that stuff
go back to the core basics hopefully
this gives you a little primer so that
when you do read the stuff on it it'll
really click but yeah that's
that's basically it
so
that's right let's just finish this
function before we go on
so yeah by reference there const so you
can't modify
by reference so it doesn't make a copy
and the out value can be modified but
now we would need to call this with an
out value so maybe we'd make a float
here
and you probably want to initialize by
the way too i'm not doing that then you
pass in result there
and now you can go
out val in equals
a times b or whatever your function does
and your result would be proper
because this is going to actually change
it
right here
so
this will be a pretty fast function
since it does everything by reference
and you would get your result
since it's such a simple function it
would be easier to just not have a
function
and just do the thing immediately but uh
yeah you probably get the point
functions typically do more than just
multiply one thing right let me know if
you like the sort of video and maybe
i'll do some more of them
happy c plus plus learning
peace out guys